okay everybody I have the honor right
now to talk to the man himself
Douglas Hodge aka Rolo Haynes from black
mirrors episode black Museum how you
doing today very well very nice to talk
to you yes
so my first question I had for you was
how did this role come about for you did
you have to audition for it
no I didn't I suppose why I'm an English
actor you know although I live in New
York but I am so I am known I suppose
over there much more than I am over here
to the makers I suppose and out of the
blue they phoned and said his script
what do you think of this and I read it
and I think I have to say I think it's
the best first script I've ever read in
my career in terms of TV or film and you
know I just the whole thing seems
completely formed there was nothing to
be rewritten or changed or anything
about it seemed funny it seemed
terrifying and it seemed daunting but it
was the darkest role I think I'd ever
undertaken and of course I am a huge
huge fan of Charlie Brooker and so I
just read it and won't go phone answered
yes that was it okay so you even have
second thoughts about taking it like you
were full-on in I was full on it all the
time while I was doing it I was a little
kind of worried about how toxic the
person was but I never had any concerns
about the piece really over the way it's
written or you know I just thought it
was wonderful and I love the series too
so yeah it was just a perfect fit okay
so you had watched some black mirror
before this or had you watched all of it
were you like a big fan of the show well
like everyone I hadn't watched all of it
because if someone just couldn't watch I
absolutely adore the show I love this
gel and I've watched right from the big
from the pig on which I mean I've
watched all of them I suppose I don't
know if some of them I liked better than
others and it's really just Christians
my taste and my politics or Who I am or
whatever and you know summer I know that
some people think oh that's my favorite
episode ever and I
different so but here I think he is a
righteous phenomenal I think the ideas
phenomenal and and I think it pushes the
boundaries of all those theories where
they should go you know and it's not
just obviously it's not just about the
future it's your tech it's about people
yeah and I think it's just a wonderful
undertaking yeah absolutely
now Douglas when this came out actually
what my audience might not know is that
Penn Jillette had wrote the short story
pain addict in the 80s and the first
story in black museum is based off of
that now it said that Penn Jillette at
one point wanted to possibly play the
role of Rollo Haynes we already casting
apart did you get any wind of this that
this was being talked about or how did
that kind of go about I had no idea that
whatsoever until after I had played the
role and then once there once the
episode came out I saw there were people
saying that and I didn't I wasn't aware
I mean I tend to just work from the
script you've got and there was enough
there to you know to make a whole world
from and and so yeah I didn't know that
no and because he would have been
fantastic
what's the both great cuz recently on
Twitter he had gone on to praise your
performance and that must have been a
really good feeling for you well I was
such a gentleman too I mean you know he
didn't need to say any of that and I
mean the feeling's mutual
and I thought not only you know is he
great and he would have been it would
have been thrilling to see him actually
but as with the way he handled the whole
thing was gentlemanly and and polite and
extremely kind and yeah I'm very
grateful to him I mean it's a dark
dangerous vicious story and it's funny
that there are there are a course all
sorts of little aspects of him in it but
it was unbeknownst to me and no I had no
idea that he was involved in it at that
point I didn't know any of the sort of
originators of the original story I
didn't know where they'd come from when
I came to it no okay I just thought it
was Charlie Brooker now for the
character of Rollo Haynes
for a character like this to get into
such a dark role is it possible to find
parts of yourself like your personal
life to get in that mindset or is that
just not possible for such like a you
could say evil person that you're
playing well I think yeah well I mean
hopefully I mean what you do is an actor
is you know it's a pretty noble way to
live your life really you just empathize
with other people you put yourself in
other people's shoes that's what you do
for a living so you try and see the
world from their point of view as
sympathetically as possible so the
elements where he is you know I mean if
you just put aside the sociopathic
psyche that's excited him you know he is
a wonderful salesman he adores tech he's
he loves to tell stories they're all
there are aspects of that that it is
that are okay to to be around and on the
day I mean when I was filmed it I really
just kept myself to myself and quite
often Leticia tried to make conversation
or people and I just thought now I'll
just stay in my corner and and keep this
whole toxic poisonous person simmering
and because it's magnificent that he
gets his comeuppance and I saw that we
only we sort of ran a sort of slightly
self-delusional thing where I'd hadn't
quite I take it in quite what was going
to happen to him so we shot everything
chronologically there was delightful in
that way that I met her and you know
introduced other things and then we we
shot the earlier scenes first so I had
that as almost memories so you know we
didn't shoot anything until the end
until the very end of the film so all
that was very helpful really the way
that Tom McCarthy directed it was some
just allowed me to sort of dupe myself
into believing I was this person I mean
he is totally unimpacted as a person and
you know misses all sorts of signals of
how to behave socially and how to be
anyway you know stay in character end
point off of set or are you able to like
snap out of this crazy role or is it
something you kind of get sucked into
completely well you do get sucked in
complete I tend to get sucked in
especially if you're doing a 14-hour
shooting day
you know you get up about 5:30 you get
in a car I I'm very quiet
I just keep myself to myself you get in
the costume you get on set and then
you're there for 14 hours you know I
mean you could be there till 8:00 p.m.
in the evening or whatever and then you
go back to your hotel I was in my own
sort of room I wasn't with anyone I
didn't really eat with anyone ever and
Cole McCarthy did this thing which is
pretty alarming to begin with where he
decided to shoot every single moment of
the film so he shot all the voiceover so
all of that does actually exist I mean
so you know even though I knew we would
be flashing back at this point and you'd
be seeing the cars arrive or you know
the people in the hospital or the guy
going down you know with the drill or
them having sex or whatever I knew those
scenes would be seen and they were
filming them he actually shot it in the
museum once you're in the museum which
was they actually built as a one-off
story so I told all the stories and he
shot all of it there was none that we
said well okay that goes to voice over
here so we'll do that in a day or in a
studio later I think we shot the entire
thing which meant that I learnt every
word of the script and sort of lived
through it really so again that was very
conducive to me just staying in my
little poisonous bubble and helps me do
it and I was just very very relief and
the whole thing was over you know it was
gross it's like just swallowing a symbol
of poison every day that's great no you
and you pulled it off completely yes
nowadays you get him a whole backstory
in your head like we know he was a
neurological research recruiter but did
you go further back like maybe in just
your mind had to create something like
why did he become this what's his
ultimate end goal as a person did you
find anything like that or you kind of
don't go that far into it yeah I suppose
I do but I on this particular role I was
more interested in what happened in
between really this stuff it's a once
you know when he's at East kr and when
he working there and he's a success and
he's and he's driving along those sort
of ideas then when he gets
from that because of ACLU and you know
they fight all those reasons that he
gives year that it was inhumane to have
less than five emotions in a you know
all those when he loses his job
I sort of tracked more what happens
between then hmm
and what sort of how many of his clothes
he would have left how much money he
would have left have left how he would
set up that Museum you know how he would
run it how successful it was for a while
what happened when that's when the
people stopped coming and they just had
the weirdos and the perverts and they
were the only people coming and how
lonely is so that really the work was to
be done from his success in between you
know the two periods in the film I think
as an actor that's sort of what I'd
concentrate it's very interesting and
was there any characters from other
movies or film or theater that you kind
of used as inspiration to maybe how
you're going to approach playing role
though hands well a lot of people have
talked about Willy Wonka because I
played Willy Wonka for a year in the in
West End I did the yeah the new version
of Charlie of the Chocolate Factory is
the musical my ire originated that role
so I played that role for a year and and
it was a sort of aspect of a completely
of dark desperate poison horrible
version of Wonka who has his own Factory
in his own logic and his own you know
inability to socialize and his own
pathological ways of behaving but it
also sort of teeters on genius so people
have said that but I I don't know there
is there were there were bits of all
sorts of people bits of Jack Nicholson
and too polite back my mind you know
also because I'm English I have sort of
different cultural references I suppose
to that sort of American person where
they've come from and how they behave
but there's also I suppose which column
and I talked about a lot a grinding your
big acting either required I mean
there's a way where you can play all
these things that you just mumble and
and you hardly show any emotion and he
constantly wanted you know which is
unfashionable these days something that
was big and unafraid yeah yeah real
storyteller and and when he dies really
dies and because you as an actor again
okay this too much you know but those
old performers like Nicolas Cage and
Jack Nicholson you know they went for
these big meaty hefty you know roles and
I there's an element of that which we
kept talking about on set you know yeah
let's let's make it yeah meaty and have
him chewing this theory I love that yeah
it's kind of out of fashion to bid yeah
to some degree and probably rightly so
and a bit sort of daunting to dive into
that but I I trusted the director
hundred-percent and he had a very very
sure I of how he was you know make
putting the whole piece together in its
look and everything so um yeah I suppose
that was in my mind yeah and I I admired
that about you because I think compared
to any other black your episode
I don't know character I had so much
dialogue that they had to handle and
keep in a consistent tone and I thought
you really nailed that I also thought
you had great chemistry with Leticia who
played nish I was wondering how much
rehearsing did you guys have prior to
filming or did you kind of just get put
into it nothing and I kept well away
from her I mean she's fantastic and
great news I'm gonna be a big star you
know I just kept myself to myself and I
thought it was more useful to do that we
didn't rehearse anything she at one
point said to me can you we should we
just run the lines to this yeah and I
said no all right and she said oh no
they never refused to run lines with me
before ever why I know that I'll be
there and I so I was pleased
my nasty towards really all the way
through you know which I hate it and and
I hope we got a chance to go out of a
beer so I could apologize to Peter
no that's that emotion of man well it
was it was a pretty daunting thing that
this scene where we electrocuted you
know
Doosan scene I still to this day didn't
know if we should be there or I mean
it's not something I adamantly don't
believe in I can't believe it still
exists in the world that people are
still doing this to each other the this
still happens in America and that was
deeply upsetting to be so I think my we
did one version where I sort of sing to
myself all the way through it which is
just so upsetting and gross but yes
there's a nasty person to be for those
months but I knew the script you know
the script is so clever and funny and
balanced and right I thought and right
on the edge yeah and on the scenes where
you're I mean look you're getting more
sick as the episode goes on you're
dripping sweat did they actually make it
hot in there for you guys to like feel
that or did you kind of have to really
improvise that no no it was never hot it
was we shot it in a on a lot in England
the nice thing was is the museum was
there you know it was it wasn't like you
could walk around to see the back of the
set they actually put it in a building
and every morning I'd get up walk into
the museum and there all the exhibits
and there was the curtain with the main
attraction at the back and the whole
thing was you know 3d he worked out and
I could sit at it and have my lunch or
whatever and then just stay there all
day and shoot and it wasn't that they
took bits of it away or it was
artificial so it's very easy to play all
that I mean I kept saying I wish they'd
kept the whole thing and you know used
it as a retraction it's incredible thing
you know if you're a fan of black
miracles it somehow they've managed to
keep stuff not just from this series but
from all the series you know and they've
gone back into the storerooms and then
put them into the exhibits the exhibits
are incredibly detailed you know which
of course a lot of which you don't see
some of which never even came to light
but it was amazing piece if it would
have been an interesting thing for any
fan to walk around you know apart from
this at home or did you like take any
little pieces of like memorabilia no I'm
still got my sunglasses that they've
taken on a whole new meaning
that's awesome so the scene where you
were put in the convicted murderers head
in the chair what are you actually
looking at during that scene like how
did they film that are you looking at
like a giant green screen when they're
doing that yeah we were in a we were in
assorted aircrafts hangouts to do huge
open area with one armchair in it and
then there was a sort of couple of red
spots on the wall you know a long way
away from me up in there in the walls
and then I just focused on them and then
they were able to play back some of her
of what they'd shot but most of it was
just read back to me I think at one
point I snapped the armchair I tried
when we were doing my little execution
him so we had to make various choices
about other men now on the day that's
him yeah again I think the way that that
whole idea of being stuck in that
monkey's head is some pretty horrific
oh yeah now with the hologram of the
convicted murderer when you guys are
filming that is there actually an actor
standing there you're looking at or were
you guys yeah yeah he was there babs's
there every day and did the whole thing
and of course is the most gentle polite
lovely intelligent guy and yeah so that
was pretty daunting - they hologram him
in post so we just shot the scene with a
he was in a Cell I was outside the cell
each time I press the button he you know
acted his response to it and we played
the scenes through the window and I
think he he had an intercom in his cell
so he could hear me and yeah so but then
later on they put this extraordinary you
know ephemeral sort of yeah in train
post Wow to make him look like the
hologram but he was there very much in
flesh and blood blessing look everyone
on the message board saying they want
more of Rolo Haines know what happened
to him but could you see a spin-off
happening maybe like in the time when
the museum was booming when you were
first like starting a museum could you
see that possibly being a thing a series
I would I would deal
love to do that but I think Charlie
Brooker is you'd never track him down
and he's so clever he's changing
everything I mean I think of Charlie a
bit like the most brilliant stand-up
comedian which is you know was he's a
very very funny man either party where
he came from but that point where you
tell jokes just to the point where you
at least go no no no no no that is
alphab that's just bad you know taste or
wrong just at the point where you start
to think this is um PC this is not right
that's about when he starts to kick in
and operate you know that feelings right
I've got some reaction here I go and so
I don't know that he'd ever repeat
himself or anything but I love the whole
to me the whole aspect of from Hitchcock
onwards you know not just Twilight Zone
and all those sort of tells from the
Crypt
you know which are obvious quotes but
the whole thing of Hitchcock and telling
stories and you know and the saying okay
this is today I'm gonna take you down
this road you know this door it's just
yeah great fun yeah yeah it would be
great to do absolutely we all want it
and I'm glad to hear that you be up for
it
and also another angle too is there a
chance for role Haynes consciousness
that was in that souvenir at the end
don't you fell off the door a little
open for maybe someone getting that
consciousness and maybe putting you back
to life in some form well I never
thought of that I'm just always sort of
in paramus screaming and I think
probably that tool that's all he
deserves his be left in that constant
hell we can go backwards into his life
but I don't know if I should ever be
saved
I think punishment that he's receiving
Douglas thank you so much for joining me
you've won a Tony you're a talented
musician you have tracks on Spotify of
music you play and you're great actor on
the screen you really do it all is there
any upcoming projects you want to
promote I'm in a play right now it's
opens Thursday night called fire and air
it's a classic stage in New York on 13th
and 3rd it's a lovely off-broadway
brand-new play by Terrence McNally and
it's all about geography
Belarusian my next movie is red Sparrow
with Jennifer Lawrence which I think
comes out March yeah that's gonna be
anonymous yeah so keep an eye out for
that and I'll just keep going all right
that we're we're excited to see you we
all love watching on screen I think this
really brought you to more American
audiences eyes in the TV world and I'm
excited to see what else you got in the
tank Douglas thank you so much for
joining me and everyone listening please
subscribe and tune in for more thanks
Douglas
all right thanks family take care bye